thanks thanks for coming to this talk
considering it's happening at the same
time as one of the llm talks I'm
thrilled to see that there are people
here um I'm going to quickly Define what
I mean by reliable rules and
specifically these are going to be rules
that persistently produce a desired
aggregate Behavior even in the face of
significant variation and uncertainty
regarding individual behaviors um I'll
get into more specifically what I mean
by that but the gist of it is that we're
going to have something that we can
control or decide in terms of the ru
making but what we actually care about
is not just whether those rules are
applied correctly but whether or not
they actually induce a desired behavior
in a larger more complex system I'm
going to take a brief aside to talk
about myself um a PhD in electrical and
systems engineering from the University
of Pennsylvania worked on multi-agent
coordination and like joint optimization
of shared resources I now um run a small
R&D firm called block science it was
founded in 2017 it's about 25 people and
although there's a bit of a
concentration in the US uh we're
actually on five continents and we
research governance economics and Tech
and largely try to assemble these
different tools into kind of cooh
coherent holistic systems again ideally
producing desired outcomes
um I'm going to come back to my
discussion of reliable rules and say
simply say that we have some sort of
system platform or Market whose
properties we care about maybe those
properties of uh in a market setting
that might be some fairness metrics it
could also Bei uh efficiencies it could
be any number of kind of constructed
metrics but these aren't just metrics
with respect to the properties of the
mechanisms or rules that that structure
the market or or the platform they're
actually properties that account for
both those rules and the behaviors they
induce and so we want to break our
problem apart into two pieces the stuff
that we can observe and control or the
stuff that our software that we're
building can observe and control and the
stuff that we can't and in our case
we're going to bundle this up as some
human preferences because we can observe
the interactions or decisions that
people take in many of these systems but
we actually don't get to observe why or
how they did it and so we don't want to
make overly strong assumptions about why
and how people are making decisions and
so we'll be exploring um I guess methods
that are derived from my background
which is control theory uh for
controlling for those uncertainties
specifically uncertainties in models and
in assumptions about the probability
distributions and a variety of other um
potential Notions of
uncertainty um so I'm not going to read
this whole slide at you this is an
invitation to go look things up on
Wikipedia um this top topics are control
engineering which is again a field of
engineering for Designing rules that
drive intended outcomes and a particular
branch of theory that corresponds to
this engineering called control theory
and what I've highlighted here is again
we're designing rule sets or mechanisms
or reactions to state that are intended
to induce system level properties um
this stuff is actually quite old
although I think relatively new to the
data science community on the
whole um basics of feedback control we
have a thing called a plant which is a
sort of system that we we hope to
control we can't see all of it we can't
even know exactly what effects we're
going to have on it but it's this
partially observable partially
controllable real world phenomena of
interest and it has a state um we have a
model of that state but we don't
actually have that state so we're going
to use some sort of sensor or
measurement apparatus some way of
collecting data and then we're going to
draw inferences from that data and then
we're going to use those inferences to
inform decisions um those decisions are
usually informed themselves by some kind
of um desired outcome Target state or
objective function that we're maximizing
for or in some cases just some kind of
properties we want to render stable um
this particular diagram is pulled out of
a paper called block diagrams for
categorical cybernetics which has got a
kind of blend of control theory and um
some more software oriented and
Mathematics language in it um but this
is the canonical sort of feedback loop
for a control system used as an example
and my invitation is for people who
think this might be cool if they want to
think about how they design rules to go
learn about this field control theory um
this map is by a guy named Brian Douglas
and he also made this video he has a
company called engineering media that
does consultancy um I'm just sort of
throwing it out there because for the
most part when I've introduced these
topics to people and they got excited
they found um this particular um
person's work to be extremely helpful
I'll have a few more links to it in the
future um we're going to be jumping in
on something uh closely related to
robust control which is up there in the
middle near the
top um and so I'm going to Define this
too um robust control is an approach to
controller design that explicitly deals
with uncertainty um
without going too far into the weeds
basically it's a methodology it's not a
specific kind of rule or a specific kind
of controller it's an approach to
defining a problem identifying the parts
of that problem definition that you know
you don't know creating models of the
gaps in your own understanding and using
those secondary models to run
exploratory experiments changing
probability distributions solving minmax
problems um finding ways to identify the
worst thing that could happen or the
various likely failure modes and then
designing to limit the risks or to
improve the performance in the worst
case
setting um and so kind of finishing up
this phase of like preemptive uh Theory
stuff um I always want to highlight this
no free lunch which basically says no
matter what we do even when we're trying
to control for the uncertainty in our
models we're going to have some model
that we're working with and a model
relies on simplifying assumptions about
the world they're always going to break
down in in some context so on one hand
we're acknowledging this and then
deploying additional methodological and
Technical Machinery to limit our
sensitivity to our modeling
assumptions but to do so we have to make
modeling assumptions so we're not
actually getting out of this trap we're
still in this trap we're just maybe
being a little bit more respectful of it
and kind of working with it and around
it um Okay so
generally speaking we're going to do
engineering processes so the firm that I
run very much comes from a a traditional
engineering discipline and so we're kind
of pulling out this example that I'm
going to run through and I'm going to
walk through the like life cycle of a
project that involved um a price setting
application a price um a price making
rule um but I'm going to take it all the
way from that particular Project's
Origins um all the way to its current
state and evolution over its life cycle
um so I'm not necessarily going to sit
here and go through a painstaking
technical detail of an application of a
robust control methodology instead I'm
going to kind of paint a picture of a
project that um went through a full life
cycle so uh this particular project is a
price controller um going back to my box
at the beginning with the sort of part
that's under our control and the part
that's not under our control in this
system we have an automated
collateralized lending platform the
primary decision that's being made here
is an adjustment to the way that the
collateral is priced which effectively
manifests like an interest rate on the
loans it's variable it can go negative
it's actually kind of interesting um in
and of itself but the key here is that
you're only really controlling this one
decision about the collateral pricing
and then everything else about how this
platform evolves is going to be
considered part of this human behavior
box who's opening loans and closing them
or paying them off are they um
defaulting and then being forced
auctioned off um are there secondary
market prices for this this collateral
that are going to affect behavior and
actually in this particular case that is
an information stream available to this
rule so we'll be actually processing
information about secondary market price
of collateral in order to compute the
new price inside of the lending
platform um that's the gist of the
application um so this part particular
one um emanates from the the web 3 space
uh there was this stable coin called D
um it was one of the first ones
introduced it was based on these
collateralized debt positions and the
original designer of this protocol had
put forth this rule for using a
stability controller rather than a fixed
dollar value for the um the asset that
they were deploying so they were taking
ethereum or e as a collateral which is
obviously very volatile so we have to
think a lot about what the consequences
of of lending against it are and um then
essentially regulating the internal uh
systems valuation of that and that
includes varying the value of the asset
issued against it the value of the asset
being loaned this particular thing did
not get implemented actually it was far
too complex for most of the people who
were working on this at the time and
they settled for a rule that involved
just fixing the price and managing the
risk through a collateralization ratio
and ensuring that these things were
massively over collateralized and
automatically liquidated but some of the
original work to analyze the stability
of the stability controller was um done
by a handful of Engineers and there's
actually a a public um article about the
stability of the class of controllers
that would regulate these lending
systems um and this is actually
originally published in 2016
so I'm kind of representing the ideation
and conceptualization phase there was
this notion that one could design a rule
that regulated this relationship between
um a more or less stable or intended to
be mostly stable medium of exchange
asset relative to a potentially very
volatile collateral asset and the idea
actually had some people who got really
excited about it and continued to
analyze it and explore it so um five
four or five years later uh a group of
Engineers raised some money to build the
thing that had been proposed or a
variation of the thing that had been
proposed um much earlier and their
project was called Ry so it was a re
reflex index so the r instead of the D
came from the preference for making this
a feedback control Rule and they
expressed narratively what how they felt
the debt repricing should work and they
wrote a white paper and explained it and
they did a rift on some of the earlier
conceptual sort of ideation simulations
but they hadn't really described a
specific set of rules and a specific set
of circumstances under which those rules
would work they just basically had come
back to the narrative the idea the
concept and so um it kind of came time
to break that problem down and actually
understand a more formal model of what
they were trying to accomplish in terms
of uh price regulation and the stability
of the relationship between the
collateral and the asset that was being
borrowed against that collateral and so
a variety of goals were determined so
smoothing secondary market price
movements without assuming a Redemption
price peg this means that the price that
this system is carrying is not going to
be the same as the market price you're
not just trying to track the market
price in some sense you're trying to low
pass filter it because it's noisy we
acknowledge that it's noisy and if it
has low frequency changes you want to
track them but if it has high frequency
CH changes you want them to filter out
you don't want to try to chase a
thrashing volatile currency um
furthermore it should be stable relative
to exogenous shock so there are these
things called flash crashes where due to
again the highly automated novel and in
some cases very problematic market
dynamics in um in the web 3 world you
don't necessarily want a system like
this to react too strongly to something
that might be a shock down and a jump
back up so whether it's because of data
Integrity or actually because of a high
frequency High magnitude Market shock
you're looking for this system to and
again not overreact to that or
destabilize in particular and finally
you want a graceful startup and shutdown
um if uh liquidity requirements fall so
again you're talking about these kind of
strange potentially um problematic low
liquidity markets and if you have
assumptions about high liquidity you
could end up with um like results that
don't play play out in practice because
if if it's not possible to make a trade
or if there's an extreme price slippage
in response to a trade then you can't
actually assume that people are going to
take those behaviors according to a um
let's say a a more reductive assessment
of an Arbitrage
opportunity um so I'm going to come back
to that now and say okay well what can
we actually control so going back to my
um statement about robust control well
this proposed controller that the people
who built this project wanted to follow
was a PID controller this is the most
common control theoretic um construct in
industrial applications it has a
proportional control gain an integral
integral control gain a derivative gain
and these are basically representing a
kind of low pass component in the
integral control a sort of you know what
is the response to the current deviation
in the proportional gain and actually a
derivative gain relates to um you know
um a weight on the the way the error is
trending um there are particulars
implementation actually only used a p
and I term so proportional and integral
controller and if you're interested in
um PID control here's another one of
those videos that I keep bringing up um
but our our work here is going to really
focus on thinking about how to select
the proportional and integral control
gains and the way in which the those
choices relate to our uncertainty about
things like our model of behavior of the
actors within the
system um so the compliment to asking
what we could control is to ask what we
cannot control um and in particular we
can't control changes to these very
volatile markets we can't um control for
people's decision to open open or close
loans definitely don't control their
incentives we could have actors who
genuinely just want to break the system
and are willing to lose money to do it
can't assume those people don't exist
um and there's a variety of other
factors that we do not control and so
we're really pushing out of our frame at
least out of our engineering frame the
idea that we can design the behavior of
these potentially economic rational
actors but also not immediately clear
what economic rational behavior is and
not immediately clear that people will
exhibit economically rational behavior
and so we want to be able to design uh
these rules for pricing these uh loans
in a way that doesn't assume those
things which is tough because most of
the Machinery that you get out of the
box at least in economics sounds like
assume a rational actor um and so we're
just not going to do that um so in order
to do this we needed to actually dive
into a representation a structured model
something that has has a a dynamical
system to it um this particular diagram
came from a repo uh that was the what I
I refer to as the kind of design digital
twin work so here we're going from you
know Gathering requirements having
conversations with people making
diagrams starting to get those diagrams
to take the form of equations and the
equations represent the various signals
and the way in which those signals are
transformed into decisions um what we've
mapped out here is the different actions
that people can take like opening and
closing loans Bally taking taking on
data or paying it off and the way in
which those depend on the system state
which includes things like the current
price of redeeming which is again what
you have to pay to pay off your loan and
so you can make money in this system if
the ratios or prices between the
collateral and the asset that you're
borrowing move in particular directions
um we're not yet assuming anything about
whether the actors are making or losing
money but we are starting to describe
that system in terms of like discrete
relations between activities in one
regime and another transition in that
into equations and transitioning that
into code and so once we have code we
have a representation of how the system
evolves as a function of behavior even
if we are not making yet strong
assumptions about behaviors um and so
now we have code and we can generate
trajectories now this is a really simple
example from a medium article it's not a
particularly sophisticated case it just
basically randomly generates eth prices
makes some modest assumptions about
people's willingness to open open or
close loans based on a shorttime horizon
of potential gains or losses um Visa
market price Redemption price
differentiation and you see a like rough
tracking here that if anything um at
least puts us on track says okay the
hypothesis there are conditions under
which this might work but we haven't
done anything yet to say what those
conditions might be and how how big of a
a basin of Attraction we might have for
making a set of rules that produces nice
tracking behavior um and so for that
there's batteries of tests in this repo
um I'm not going to try to belabor them
but you're there are shock tests there
are worst case scenario tests there's a
a variety of different models I think
there are three different versions of
this model in this repo and some of them
include these um this actually this
thing is quite tall so if you were to
scroll down this PNG you see these
various tests you know they input shocks
system responses computations of
overshoot undershoot recovery metrics
response times just kind of getting a
flavor for how these systems behave and
then actually also variances over those
responses um this work was done by uh um
danillo um Ben Schultz and um I think
some of the earlier work was done by
Marcus kooch um the the work itself uh
really explored the design space here
and eventually led to a set of metrics
that were given to the team that was
building it and they made a selection to
go with a simple P term only controller
at launch and so they launched this into
production um I believe it was February
13th 2021 and so this rule that encodes
the price setting via the P controller
archetype with all the tests really just
boiling down to where do we think it's
safe to set the gains uh the parameters
of this controller and they went live
um interestingly enough there's a second
repo that involves a bunch of monitoring
apparatus so this is a description of an
architecture of a basically a systems
identification system so you have a
model of the um the plant uh the and you
have a model of the controller and you
are collecting data to try to fit and
extrapolate the various ways in which
the system might evolve in the future um
the work here was done as part of a an
education process actually and some of
it was adopted into what I believe is a
Clos Source implementation um being used
by people monitoring the system uh
there's a more explicit version of the
extrapolation code that was a variant or
a fork built by the team available uh
the the reflexor labs team on their
website so here I grabbed a screenshot
of it um this was actually from
yesterday so it's uh able to show you
historical effects of the PE
rate and there there is an i rate now
which I'll I'll mention in a moment and
so you can actually see the historical
data these are being pulled straight
from the onchain infrastructure um into
a I believe it's a subgraph for the
graph as a staging in a database that's
graphql and then it's used as a data
source for um the analysis and plots and
their website on stat their stats
website has various different
extrapolations with different
assumptions as a the day you're actually
looking at their website which is pretty
cool um gives people at least some
information about the way the system's
trending from the re from the real data
and actually I mentioned that they
launched with an IT term with without an
iterm but they did later introduce one
and they did later change it so they're
exercising governance over this so our
quote unquote governance surface is the
parameters of the controller and so as
far as they're regulating a sort of
small economy in the form of this
lending platform they're primary mode of
governance is actually to make small
tweaks to um to these Ki uh and and Pi
or KP Ki and KP parameters that
represent the gains in the um P ID
controler or the pi controller which in
turn regulate their pricing rule which
in turn regulates their economy and so
you get this actually really interesting
system with a a governance apparatus
with forums and discussions and
approvals to make changes to their um
key parameters these various pieces of
software that at different times got
used to design and or evaluate the state
of that economic system and a admittedly
relatively small total user base I think
right now there are a few maybe 4,000
people actively engaging like holding
this asset and using it um there have
been more over um over its lifetime but
it's been several years now I think
we're something like three years into
the experiment um so it's been pretty
interesting to follow along with I've
also um helped some members of my team
build some um some actual trading
strategies like designing hybrid systems
rules um under which states of the
public data does it make sense to take
on loans versus to pay off loans you
have if you're profit maximizing that's
an interesting kind of um alternative
player view instead of viewing the
system from the perspective of Designing
this economy stabilizing this otherwise
noisy relation between the collateral
and this um mostly stable asset I think
it's total price change in three years
is 30 cents so it went from I think Pi
it was launched at
3.14 uh dollar value and I think it's
something like
2.75 um and so through that entire
variation and all the um nonsense in
crypto markets this particular sort of
self-regulated asset manag to stay more
or less stable again despite all these
transients a total 30 30 cents roughly
10% variation in its overall price and
that included some of these higher order
responses to add the I term and to tweak
it later as a result of um discourse
within their forums and discussions
amongst the people who are stakeholders
to the system and so that's it um big
overview um we did a lot of our analysis
using an open source tool called cad
actually Joshua wrote it um and it um
wrote it a couple years ago we use it as
an alternative to mat lab for
um uh for building simulations and
analyzing dynamical systems there's some
links for the design digital twin and
operational digital twin repo neither of
them are in active present use but they
were artifacts of the various stages in
the life cycle of this project um
there's some articles about
um this particular project that I linked
throughout and there's some videos about
methodologies that we use um parameter
selection on uncertainty which is most
closely related to robust control and
generalized dynamical systems which we
use to describe these systems and so as
a last kind of call to action um I've
been working with some Partners they're
all down here token engineering Commons
ocean protocol open teams incubator
Quant site Etc um to sort of get a small
pool of grant funding for who are
interested in exploring the data sets
and code bases that are in the web 3
World um I don't work exclusively in the
web 3 world but I do find it really
compelling that you can look directly at
the uh the data uh associated with
individual behavior and that people have
kind of opted into this sort of opsource
um approach to making and following
rules so there's some really interesting
data sets um the small grants program
has a um uh an application it's mostly
for people interested in just kind of
probing how to apply numpy scipi s kit
learn networkx other tools from this
ecosystem uh to analyze or explore some
of these data sets so if you scan that
you'll get a link the link takes you to
a website and the website lets you kind
of drop in a idea for a project and get
um it's not huge amount of funding but
it's a nice opportunity to get a little
bit of funding behind an exploratory
project so the the R&D company that I
run has basically three working groups
one on governance one on economics and
one on Tech and a big part of our
company is to try to figure out how to
make these blocks fit together into real
things and um obviously real things can
take the form of um uh like these kinds
of lending platforms that I discussed
with the web 3 application we've also
done work with the Red Cross we're
currently working on a um a grant
project related to um measuring
environmental um impact sort of house
related stuff for Canadian under a
Canadian Grant with a Canadian nonprofit
and um it's actually a pretty broad uh
space where we have these
computational um platforms now measuring
and deciding so many things um we want
to be really careful about what
technologies we're using what kind of
economic resource allocations they're
inviting either in terms of how we
measure and how we allocate resources
and then ultimately who that affects and
how make sure that the right
stakeholders are party to decisions
about those systems and I I liked this
example because it was just a very
public one where all three of these
things came into play smart contracts
are a particular piece of technology
that made it possible to implement this
thing it's very much a question of
allocating resources albeit particularly
Financial one um but there was even this
activity of updating the parameters of
the pricing controller as a governance
action for the stakeholders to that
system
[Applause]
than